يبدو ان الامور حتى هذه اللحظه او لاطل
الملك اطل الملك الان من شرطه القصر الى
جانب زوجته كملا ايضا
ويتقدمان الان لربما القاء التحيه كذلك
على الاف المحتشدين من الجماهير رفقه
اعضاء الاسره الملكيه ايضا الملك يلقي
التحيه الان على كل هذه الجماهير التي
تحتشد وهو كما ذكرنا يرتدي التاج التاج
الامبراطوري
وكذلك ايضا الملكه كميلا ترتدي تاج الملكه
لك
[تصفيق]
صحيح تم يعني فك الطوق الامني فورا انتهاء
القوات المسلحه من دول من بريطانيا ودول
الكومنويل 30 على اقل
فتحت الطرقات وسمح للناس بالتوجه الى محيط
قصر بالهام افتاحا بالمجال الملك لخروجه
بالجد
ول من المتوقع ان يطل الملك على الشرفه
قبل عشر دقائق هذا هو الان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التي يعني يحيي فيها الجماهير الملك
والملكه
مهم جدا ان نرى من سيكون على الشرطه في
هذه الاثناء لماذا لانه هذه هي
الرسائل السي
اسيه شراء التي يعطيها الملك ريما ان كنت
تشاهدين امامك الشاشه الان او ربما الهاتف
المتنقل لمشاهده البث المباشر لكن يتواجد
الامير ويليام وكذلك ايضا الاميره ان زوجه
او عفوا اخت الملك تشارلز لا اعلم ان كنت
تشاهدين
[تصفيق]
انا ارى افراد العائله الملكيه نرى ان
الاحفاد والامير وليم ولي العهد
والملكه الجميع متواجد على شرطه لا وجود
الامير هاري وهو شقيق ولي العهد وهناك
ايضا افراد من عائله كاملا على ما اظن
موجودين على
شيء وهذا اصلا كان الاتفاق لكن بقي وطبعا
زوجه ولي العهد موجوده على الشرطه
قالت الاعلام البريطانيه كانت تتكاهن من
سيكون على هذه الش
رطه يغيب من سيحضر
هذه مشاهد ولي العهد وزوجته الاميره كيد
والابناء ابناء الامير ويليام طبعا الثالث
هو الامير جورج وهو الثالث في ترتيب العرش
الملك تشارز متوجا والملكه كاملا احفاد
كاملا من زوجها الاول باركربون على فكره
حتى زوج كان داخل زوج الاول للملكه كاملا
كان داخل الكنيسه وحتى كما قرانا كان بعرس
تشارلز وكابيلا بقيت العائله متماسكه نوعا
ما رغم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات